no small amount of excitement in the
corridors as any piece gathered for the
first parliamentary session after maze
elections the selection of the new
president the top item before that
though a European tradition then to
business with four candidates standing
many of them critical of the way in
which the e use top posts are being
filled we should not simply be presented
with a precooked deal to just
rubber-stamp do you vote for the
backroom deal or do you vote for a
Europe of openness transparency
democracy and hope el mejor patrimonio
de europa es la voluntad de sus to da da
nose day sir libras y no sir seer voz de
nadie halters envia declare the demo
Cartesian Ligety Marchione ela oppa mr.
shoots himself won by a hefty margin in
the first ballot he picked out
unemployment trade deal with the US and
immigration as key priorities for the
coming term afterwards though there was
lingering anger at the manner of his
selection it's no surprise people from
outside of this very closeted chamber
are really going to feel that their
voice counts for nothing there are
certain groupings of individuals within
this Parliament who are just going to do
whatever they want it was a deal between
the Socialists and the Conservatives
ideal like the big deal in in Germany
the big deal in Greece and the big deal
in my country they are dealing the
Arabic collision that at our imposing
terrible terrible austerity politics in
in our country others however defended
the process is fair and democratic there
was a clear majority that's a normal
procedure all over Europe in all the
parliaments it's there are proposals
from groups and there is at the end the
maturity and I think it's a good start
we we show to the public to the people
to our voters said we could guarantee
that the European Parliament is ready we
could start as our in the coming weeks
there are many more posts to be filled
not least the now-vacant head of the
socialist group as well as a new batch
of European commissioners and council
heads it may be some time before
Parliament can crack on with its
legislative agenda